we have a lot to catch up on today not
the least of which is hatred mail quick
reminder here's what hatred mail is a
fine Rand and Ronald Reagan had a baby
and suckled that child off the teat of
Liberty its cries would sound a little
something like Patriot mail written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America because freedom okay
this week's hatred mail it quite
literally has no introduction because
I'm not going to give it one here it is
agenda agenda agenda Europe in cuc go
away globalist criminal empire
propaganda go away Pakman this Pakman
kid is a snowflake thinking he can is
question of the integrity of this
gentlemen of who has the experience as
he does in the field this guy is a
stooge the [ __ ] ape Muslim failed and
you demon rats will not win a
presidential election for at least 50
years because of this own bum bud
Schrader
this is what I call hatred bingo right I
mean it basically had the only thing it
was missing was a misspelling of your
rights that's the only thing it was
missing from typical hey tree at Bingo
do you like being called a kid in this
scenario I was my Hockman kid I don't
mind I don't mind yeah people don't
realize I'm in my early 30s but yeah
that's it that's I have a feeling I'm
gonna like that more and more as the
years go use hatred mail to do something
positive for independent media the
coupon code hey tree at 40 is available
to you at david pakman.com slash
membership